des bises et des accolades maryse dé ses
camarades débute la journée avec le
sourire mais pas de temps à perdre pour
ces bénévoles
il faut décharger les camions des balles
et les marchandises et les mettre en
rayon il faut tout ranger pourquoi 11h30
ce soit terminé
pourquoi ben c'est parce qu'ils
apprennent où on va on va trancher
non m à moins qu en reste harris
dynamique retraitée consacre deux jours
par semaine aux restos du coeur
elle a pourtant des enfants et des
petits enfants et donc un emploi du
temps assez chargé
mais pour cette ancienne aide soignante
venir ici était une évidence
après la retraite j'ai continué à
travailler trois ans ce jugement en
juillet et ensuite et bien je suis venu
aux restos du coeur
je voulais des je voulais être utile je
voudrais pas rester à rien faire donc je
vais aider donc ici j'ai trouvé ma place
vous déjeunez chacun apporte son repas
l'occasion d'échangés entre les anciens
comme 10 25 ans de bénévolat derrière
lui et les jeunes comme maryse arrivé au
resto il y a trois ans c'est très bien
il faut il faut la relève n'a pas
comment surtout comment la marine us
titi mari qui semble assez avoir le
sourire et tenter de le communiquer aux
bénéficiaires c'est l'un des objectifs
de marine oui c'est difficile parce que
des fois on a envie de tendre un peu
plus la main mais bon ils sont tous ici
pareil retraités familles étudiants ils
sont tous là pour recevoir la même chose
donc on essaye de garder pour nous ce
qu'on ressent 14h les restos ouvrent
leurs portes
les bénévoles vont servir 35
bénéficiaires et réalisé presque autant
de nouvelles inscriptions